chuckle what do you think about when you
don't feel like getting after it you
know I put this out the other day and I
think it's important all right
so rome wasn't built in a day we all
know that everyone's hears that but rome
also didn't fall apart overnight either
it took hundreds of years for Rome to
reach its peak but it also took time
hundreds of years for Rome to decay and
fall apart and that is representative of
life because you don't achieve
worthwhile goals quickly or easily they
take time they take struggle they take
relentless pursuit day in and day out
that's what it takes but also things
don't usually fall apart quickly either
at least at first it's it's a slow
process a little slip here a little
setback over there
a little wearing down of discipline and
will over time that's the thing success
and failure are generally slow processes
either slowly building things up or
gradually tearing them down
and that's why I say you've got to pay
attention you have to watch you have to
watch every single second because those
seconds they turn into minutes then
minutes turn into hours and hours turn
into days and days turn in to years and
so that second that second that just
went by that counted and so did that
second and so did that one
and in those precious seconds you are
either building or you're decaying you
are either gaining ground or you were
losing ground in that second and in
every second
every second counts
so make every second count